hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu gefixt
dank der tollen twitter funktion hat mir
geschrieben #fb lpl kupfer und zinn in
die werkbank packen dann bekommen wir
angeblich bronze das projekt jetzt erst
mal aus und nebenbei kann ich wäre
einfach der dax genau du hast aber den
namen christlicher jong oder so etwas
und ja ich hole ich habe schon das ganze
kupfer du holst in ja ich habe rede
du bist bei mir unsichtbar alter ja ja
gebe deswegen habe ich noch nicht
gesehen du mein gott du hast einfach nur
zehn in der hand das einfach nur zehn
schwebt in der luft gemacht ganz l vom
server nein das ist das wichtig ich bin
ich bin hier neben dir a ha ha hier
liegt das ziel war es mal brennt liegt
bei mir aber eigentlich nicht an mir
wenn ich dich nicht sehen kann ende der
datenübertragung ist der conny weg dann
fangen schon mal an zwei tagen erwarte
jetzt geht es glaube ich ja egal
jedenfalls wir waren in dieser
konfiguration verfasser der letzten
folge ging es darum dass ich erzähler
wie wir uns kennengelernt haben und was
mein erster eindruck von kombibahn
basiert so bekommt er denke und jetzt
kommt noch dazu seine rennszene die
werkbank geht nicht weil er es
wahrscheinlich einmal englischen einmal
deutsches material es geht das ist das
liegt dann mach du mal durch erzählt
test einfach um reicht benehmen nebenbei
bis ins detail sienerth das war einfach
so
dieser konnte nicht gefragt wäre es
unschwer so ganz neutral eigentlich man
weiß ja einfach immer selber ob die
frage jetzt in die arrogante oder nicht
und alle haben das halt normal
aufgefassten das neue youtube haben auch
normal geantwortet und dann kommt dieser
unschwer an luca man einfach so mit
genau der gleichen frage anstatt
irgendwie auch zu antworten ja hey ich
bin neu hier und so daher ja gedacht so
ja ok cool aber dann kommt er einfach
sein herz bekommen dann habe ich einfach
auch so dumm geantwortet wie du meinst
du ich bin niemand weil ich wollte halt
damit bezwecken dass du verstehst dass
das was ich bin erst mal scheißegal ist
welche wissen wollte wer du bist so war
ich halt noch nicht kannte mich alle
anderen kannte so jedenfalls verändert
sich das alles so klingt gleich gesagt
dass du dir doch was für gedanken machst
machen aber vieles gedanken ich habe mir
nur gedacht ich sehe da ganz kurz ein
wenn du nur gedacht ich habe mir nur
gedacht nur weil so viele abonnenten
hass muss ich dir nicht den arsch
kriechen dass es richtig macht ok cool
gut dann war irgendwann
dieses event halt und danach dann habe
ich irgendwann probleme gespielt mit
karte und ich hatte kein vip und konnte
daher nicht auf einige server und hatte
auch nicht deswegen habe ich so gefragt
hey weiß angeblich bekommt ja frag mal
hier und schwer so aus dass der aus der
gruppe nicht einmal hat er dich rein
gezogen und meinte dann so wie rapid
blatt und habe deshalb gemacht und ich
fand ich halt eigentlich ich habe mir
vorher gar nicht über dich gedanken
gemacht ich hatte einen kanal ja nicht
ich kannte dich ja gar nicht von daher
keine ahnung hätte auch ein kann
deswegen großer amerikanischer youtuber
gewesen hätte ich die frage genau gleich
formuliert wird der nahverkehr an schwer
anschwimmen dasteht falls hast du mir
dann erklärt wie man david bekommt wie
man daher babo wird und so und dann war
das eigentlich alles ganz gut verbunden
aufgenommen und dann irgendwann später
habe ich dann die sixties entdeckt und
ich wollte das eigentlich vorher
mitmachen aber wir hatten dann irgendwie
keinen bock auf ingesamt ganz ganz
langes projekt weil bei uns beiden die
zeit für den relativ schlechtes du weißt
bei mir ich habe fast nie zeit also du
bist ja immer neue tass am pc ich hab
kein leben genau habe ich damit sie man
einfach so gefallen bis angeguckt weil
eigenständigen und das dann einfach so
gemacht und ich hätte nie gedacht dass
simon denkt dass ich so arrogant sei
unklar
aber ich mache auch mit denen zum
beispiel was der auch weniger bunten hat
als unglaublich den erkannte schon früh
und ich kann ich nämlich auch ganz
einfach gar nichts tun hatte damit ich
mal den angeguckt aber den autor damals
richtig viel mit mir gemacht aber ich
kannte hat mit der micro anguckt früher
weil ich gespielt habe so
du bist ja ein minecraft kanal receiver
bald ändern
so ist hast du schon erzählt ja im
nächsten jahr ist es wieder mich ändern
bisschen boylan hierfür die leute die
treuen zuschauer es wird sich nicht es
wird sich nicht ändern
nein es bleibt minecraft altlasten
ausmalung getätigt brauche mir mehr
setzlinge egal so war es auf jeden fall
und dann hatten wegen kontakt und das
gemacht in diesem das und wieder leute
auch immer gefragt
demba ba hatte erst vor den streit die
man hat alles kaputt im machtbereich
natürlich alltag und das ausgibt was du
an einem schild ist jedenfalls du machst
das alles tue ich weiß nicht wo das
wasser her kriege junge du musst das vom
rand neben von solchen sachen hiervon
hier hier hier blog drunter ist dann
dann ist es normal
ach scheiße junge guck mal das ist alles
total die strömungen hier ja es ist ein
reißender fluss ist ehrlich ich mache es
wäre reparieren ich mache alles wieder
repariert
außerdem konnte eigentlich der weg wurde
ihr wasser eingebracht das bekommt auch
der weg hin was hier kommt auch der weg
hin welcher weg der weg der von mach das
ja das ist auch super ist ein richtiger
daniel es geht danach dass wirklich dann
hier so entlang genau so lang
was lars so geht er weg geht hier gar
niemand hier landen hier so hatte
vom boss wird er dahin überhaupt war das
der weg wird
ich wollte nur zeigen wie komplex
erleben was machst du da zu kurz
nein du selbst deine lebens stellen was
möchtest du auch immer ihr wird den
klinkerbau top daher wird auch nicht
schaden denkt dran
die handball-fans leben der gewinn der
gewinnt das schon wieder geschlagen
naja ich hab dich geschlagen denkens
quali wenn du willst eisleben am
schlossplatz werden versichert er
gewinnt trotzdem gut
warum denkst du wirst weil ich dort dann
schlechthin
aber du hast die seite minecraft kann
man kein kind ja man kann auch kein
skill habe ich wirklich nicht auszugehen
hab ich erstmal wir brauchen jetzt
erstmal die macht mein wohnzimmer
beantwortet deniz geht nicht ja genau an
bord
rechtsanwalt wiederholen musste kia guck
mal soviel der unser weg entlang bin ich
schön
um zu fahren dafür braucht man kupfer
okay okay okay geht doch inzwischen
sowohl wo hast du das ganze kunst und
sohin jetzt an die truhe die links
direkt rechts
und immer freunde ja ja so geht das
okay wir haben jetzt 36 gebaut und alte
positionen
okay ich hab jetzt eine ranch damit kann
ich jetzt das hier abbauen
hey was labert der es gibt vor langsam
ich will ich traue mich nicht dass damit
abzubauen okay es geht bei den anderen
sachen auch so langsam aber muss einfach
noch einmal mächtig machen lassen sowie
haben den generator jetzt daran gepackt
gut wie viel scheiße vier minuten ist
das jetzt schon wieder acht aber wenn
ihnen doch jetzt erstmal noch nie dass
ich die letzte folge wird aufnehmen
danach könnt ihr kommentare weil
minister jetzt auch dann hochland bis
heute ich bin ja richtig weil der conti
chef
das ist problem so in der nächsten folge
wäre ich dann in rabat zur aber machen
und screen zu halten und dann könnt ihr
mir wieder ganz können jetzt wieder ganz
den kommentaren schreiben was man als
nächstes machen sollen
ein verkehrter entwickeln muss
trainingsplan
was machst du das ein scheißjob penner
nee das ist auch mutter mit mann der
weiß wo der gegner ja ich habe aber auch
gesehen sagte letztlich also direkt vor
allerdings gemein
man geht hier so lang dann geht man hier
so und her kommt noch so jedoch noch
dieses wien ma das grau ist apple genau
könnten aber theoretisch möglich andere
blockieren packen werde so viele hier
kommt dann der weg in der genau ich
möchte so bisschen träge verlaufen haben
und hier kommt das feld in wie find das
feld bis jetzt so schön weil er mit er
fragt mich als achter de ja ich versuche
ist gar nicht gut
ach ja da hinten habe ich den ganzen
links im winzigen blüten glauben blüten
nummer eins war noch habe nortel an
helfen mit der spitzhacke hier 20
sekunden können ein bisschen länger
machen vor - okay machen auch ganz
schnell hier das feld agrarwirtschaft
und so heißt es da
herr pastor perfekt klassisch ist gut
dass es bestimmt bertram vogel sun
berichtet mir die crew wollte lieber
lebe wollte sich parker noch ein paar
fackel denn damit sie ein bisschen
verwirrt schon wieder dunkel nicht lange
mit schlafen geht folge zu ende da jetzt
noch mittun mit der atom noch das feld
schnell anpacken wartet 30
wir sind schon längst über die zeit zehn
minuten vor der zeit ist das was
pünktlichkeit ihrer zeit ist das bei
unpünktlich gehört die felder ich sagte
wenn die pflanze ist echt schön echt
schön
ja das gleiche denke ich mir hier bei
dem dings auf
bei der baum fahren dazu braucht es um
das neue einfach hin los aber ich finde
das gut dass du das machst du glaub ich
ein bisschen drüber ziehen uns passt das
nicht so ganz wie ich mir das vorstelle
1 2 1 2
die ungeheuer die dachte ich an die
monster kommen jetzt und das ganze ding
noch mal sehr hätten schon nicht serien
feature das rosa keeper gehts um braun
vermisst nicht symmetrisch naja egal ich
würde sagen wir machen jetzt erstmal cup
für die so viele lieber vorsichtig
apella bist du penner number one
da kommt nachher noch darauf dass kern
wieder komplett einmal gar nichts
passiert aber ich würde sagen wir schon
mal einiges geschafft auch so sachen die
man nicht so sieht also wir haben das da
umgestellt und so und landclub ja
freunde natürlich sagen wie man wenn es
euch gefallen hat durch die eine
positive bewertung abgeben
ihr dürft das wir glauben euch das bag
weiter kommentare schreiben und so ab
jetzt computer wieder angesagt denn die
nächste folge wird dann das nächste mal
aufgenommen